لا أريد أن أموت في هذا الأمر
يتجه نحونا،
أصدر مكتب عمدة مقاطعة سبوكان لقطات من كاميرا الجسم تظهر
أحد نوابه وهو يقود سيارته عبر
حريق طريق أوريغون بعد وقت قصير من بدايته في
18 أغسطس، لكنك لن تفهمني
اليوم
إنه يتجه نحونا يا رجل لقد كنت
هناك
إلا إذا كنت تريد أن تموت كان النائب بريتون
مورغان يعمل على إجلاء
سكان المنطقة من حرائق الغابات سريعة الحركة أوه،
شكرًا لك يا أخي، لقد كنت قلقًا جدًا عليك، هل
أنت بخير، أعلم أنك على الأرجح حزين عليه
خيولك الآن يا أخي، أنا سعيد لأنك على
قيد الحياة، قال مكتب الشريف إنه قام
بتحرير الفيديو للغة والوقت
ولطمس وجوه المنزل الرمادي بالمنزل الوردي
الفاتح، ما هو العنوان الذي
أودى فيه حريق طريق أوريغون بحياة شخص واحد
ودمره؟  لا يزال مسؤولو 120 منزلاً على الأقل
يعملون على تقييم
إجمالي الأضرار وفقًا
لمكتب الشريف